players had lillard second behind steph  curry  and as disappointing as it is it it the  all-star game is about the fans  that's part of the reason why uh you  know the league is having one this year  it's their number one  fan engagement activity the all-star  weekend and so  you know the van the fans still have a  huge voice as we see caruso with the  duck  portland now says marcus saw with a good  little dime and  laker fans see that from alex caruso all  the time  you can't even call it sneaky hops at  this point  [Applause]  entry pass is picked off by james his  fourth steal and a great pass ahead  caruso with another dunk timeout  portland  [Applause]  lebron james with 21